un jour ordinaire à bagdad sanglant
trois ans après le début de la guerre
l'irak est toujours un champ de bataille
[Musique]
cet été l'armée américaines
comptabilisaient 70 attaques par jour
rien que dans la capitale irakienne ce
restaurant était fréquenté par des
policiers un kamikaze vient de s'y faire
sauter il ya eu cinq morts et 15 blessés
quelques trente mille civils ont été
tués depuis la chute de saddam hussein
l'irak et son pétrole font l'objet de
toutes les convoitises
il se dit à bagdad une vingtaine de
services secrets de toutes nationalités
y opère une véritable guerre secrète
pour ce reportage
je suis escortée en permanence par six
gardes du corps et ne me déplace qu'en
voiture blindée bagdad n'est pas sûre
malgré les contrôles incessants des
troupes américaines et irakiennes et les
patrouilles des sociétés militaires
privées 25 mille mercenaires réputés
pour leurs cachettes facile on les
reconnaît à leur 4 4 blindés blancs car
bagdad et aux mains d'autres milices -
officiel mais tout aussi dangereuse pour
en parler ce journaliste irakien a
préfère l'anonymat
ce n'est pas une guerre civile mais une
guerre 2006 une guerre de milices qui
sont ces milices qui les aide qui les
soutient on évoque l'activisme de
l'arabie saoudite de la jordanie ou de
la syrie parmi les sunnites et les
anciens partisans de saddam hussein
mais c'est l'iran qui serait en sous
main le pays le plus influent en irak
l'iran qui soutiendrait les groupes
armés les plus puissants il est vrai que
l'iran supporte certaines des milices
qui agissent en irak
il est vrai que l'iran finance ces
milices il est vrai aussi que l'iran
entraîne certaines de ces mais il est
aussi certain que les services iraniens
aux pertes en irak
il est évident que les rangs exerce une
influence sur l'irak
c'est la deuxième dans le pays après la
présence militaire américaine l'iran
l'iraq partagent plus de 1400 kilomètres
de frontière la plus longue frontière
terrestre pour ces deux pays mais ils
ont en commun aussi une religion le
chiisme
60% des irakiens sont de confession
chiite comme 90% des iraniens
et les lieux saints les plus sacrées des
chiites se trouvent en irak comme le
confiance et ayatollahs irakien le
centre du monde pour les chiites se
trouvent en irak
ce n'est pas l'iran alors c'est pas
environ 6 en irak
nous sommes à téhéran le 9 février
dernier c'est la choura le jour le plus
important pour les chiites
la commémoration du martyre de hussein
petit fils de mahomet en l'an 680 à la
bataille de kerbala
hussein qui marchaient sur bagdad avec
son armée fut défait par les troupes du
calife yazid premier une scène aurait
été décapité son corps mutilé toute son
armée ainsi que sa famille décimée tient
la première bataille entre sunnites et
chiites dans les rues de téhéran
le rite est identique à celui des rues
de kerbala en irak
les gestes sont mêmes ils pleurent tous
le martyre d'hussein le guide de tous
les chiites
voilà malgré la différence de langue
entre le farsi et l'arabe
ce qui unit depuis plus de 1300 ans les
iraniens aux irakiens
à
[Musique]
aujourd'hui karbala est une ville sainte
chiite et sous son dôme d'or reposerait
la dépouille du cèdre pour les chiffres
du monde entier le pèlerinage à kerbala
est presque aussi important que le
voyage à la mecque saddam hussein de
confession sunnite en avaient
déconseillé la pratique depuis sa chute
quelques quinze mille personnes viennent
tous les jours se prosterner devant la
tombe du scène il traverse temps car à
l'irak ravagé par la guerre
guidés par leur fois plus forte que la
peur ils n'hésitent pas à venir en
famille du monde entier je viens de
bombay en inde
on représente la communauté chiite
indienne je suis avec toute ma famille
on est cinq personnes mais c'est
dangereux pour votre famille non non non
il n'y a pas de problème une véritable
industrie touristique a pris son essor à
kerbala hôtel tout neufs cars et agences
de voyages tout est fait pour accueillir
les groupes de pèlerins
[Musique]
rien ne manque à la visite du temps
encore moins ses marchands pour les
iraniens aussi kerbala est redevenu un
lieu de pèlerinage
malgré la guerre et la présence
américaine massoud homme d'affaires
iranien et sa famille n'ont pas hésité à
traverser une bonne partie de l'irak
pour leurs vacances
on est venus tous ensemble mon père ma
mère
voici ma famille
lui c'est mon père c'est ma femme et ma
mère ces lieux sont sacrées pour nous
d'ailleurs pas seulement pour nous mais
pour tous les chiites
il n'y a pas de différence entre les
chiites iraniens et irakiens
les chiites et sunnites sont aussi des
frères ici on oublierait presque que
l'irak est en guerre mais deux jours
auparavant
trois obus ont été tirés sur la ville
sainte pas de quoi décourager massoud
remonté contre les américains
on n'a pas peur des américains
depuis des années nous considérons
l'amérique comme un pays satanique
parce qu'elle intervient dans les
affaires internes de tous les pays c'est
un pays qui veut dominer le monde
ce n'est pas un pays ami c'est notre
ennemi quelles que soient les iraniens
que nous rencontrons ils ont tous la
même haine de l'amérique
regardez aujourd'hui l'amérique et
l'angleterre sont dans ce pays
elle emporte toute la richesse de ces
pauvres gens ahmed abu mustafa et le
gouverneur de la région
tous les matins il reçoit les chiffres
des pèlerins de la veille il nous
confirme que les iraniens sur les
premiers touristes étrangers en irak
la majorité des touristes sont iraniens
il ya un contrat entre les gouvernements
irakien et iraniens pour laisser rentrer
les touristes iraniens ils viennent
visiter l'imam ali nadjaf et kerbala
il ya en moyenne 1500 touristes iraniens
par jour ils restent en général trois
jours à nadja et 4 jouera qu'un malade
[Musique]
les autorités religieuses iraniennes
soigne particulièrement les villes
saintes irakiennes
elle sera même fourni les 60 kg d'or
pour recouvrir le dôme sacré de kerbala
mais l'influencé iranienne ne se limite
pas aux lieux saints elle est aussi
politique
pour s'en convaincre il suffit de se
rendre au siège du sri le conseil
suprême de la révolution islamique en
irak un des plus puissants partis
politiques chiites
aujourd'hui dans le pays rencontre avec
le dignitaire local
c'est pas que nous ayons un penchant
pour les rangs nous ne leur donnons pas
la priorité sur d'autres pays
mais c'est vrai c'est un pays envers
lequel nous sommes particulièrement
reconnaissants
ni plus ni moins sachez que tous nos
chefs que tous les partis islamiques
irakien même des partis libéraux ont
trouvé refuge en iran sous saddam le sri
a été fondée en iran par l'ayatollah
al-hakim farouche opposant de saddam
hussein en avril 2003 après 23 ans
d'exil
son retour est triomphal
mais prêchant la coopération avec les
américains l'ayatollah al-hakim sera
victime d'un attentat
quatre mois plus tard
de retour au pays ses milliers de
partisans armés et entraînés par l'iran
pour combattre saddam hussein vont
former l'une des ministres les mieux
armés d'irak et le sri devenir un parti
politique incontournable
fort de son image de résistance anti
saddam et de son engagement islamique
le sri s'impose dans les urnes aux
premières élections multipartites au
sein de l'alliance unifiée irakienne une
coalition chiite conservatrice les
chiites obtiendront la moitié des postes
au sein du gouvernement transitoire
irakien six mois plus tard la coalition
chiites fondamentalistes religieux
obtiendra une victoire totale à bagdad
et dans le sud de l'irak aux élections
législatives
rendez-vous au parlement avec le chef
guy al din al fayed porte-parole dustrit
cet homme a passé trente ans d'exil en
iran et ne tarit pas d'éloges sur ses
anciens protecteurs autant de la lutte
contre saddam
l'iran a été notre seul soutien montre
une véritable volonté d'aider l'irak
la preuve c'est que lors des premières
élections celles qui ont porté au
pouvoir jafari le gouvernement iranien a
tout de suite offert comme cadeau
gouvernement provisoire un milliard de
dollars au nom de cette nouvelle amitié
l'iran d'ahmadinejad envisagerait même
selon notre interlocuteur d'annuler la
dette de l'irak à son égard une dette de
plusieurs milliards de dollars en
compensation des dégâts occasionnés par
la guerre iran irak en avril 2006
téhéran a même nommé un ambassadeur à
bagdad
une première depuis un quart de siècle
l' influence iranienne va bien au delà
des négociations diplomatiques et de
l'assistance économique elle est aussi
idéologique dans sa lutte d'influencé
avec les etats-unis en irak l'iran
s'appuie aussi sur une partie des
mosquées chiites retour à karbala
cette école coranique vient de réouvrir
ses portes après des années de fermeture
sous saddam hussein l'homme qui la
dirige s'était réfugié à qom en iran
l'ayatollah mohammad taqi al moudarrès y
rentrer d'exil son discours incitent
ouvertement les fidèles à rejoindre les
milices chiites
l'existence des milices est nécessaire
pour assurer notre autodéfense
si le pouvoir en place ne sort pas un
système pour affronter les défis qui se
présentent
il n'ya pas d'autre alternative dans ce
pays que les milices la preuve dans le
nord de l'irak il n'y a pas de problème
ce sont les milices kurdes qui assurent
la sécurité
et pourquoi ce serait autorisée pour les
autres et pas pour nous les chiites
trois ans après l'intervention
américaine
il flotte en irak un parfum de guerre
civile
les affrontements entre groupes
confessionnels chiites et sunnites n'ont
jamais été aussi 100 euros
le gouvernement irakien et c'est de
désarmer les milices en intégrant leurs
hommes dans les forces de sécurité mais
c'est au risque du noyautage de l'armée
et de la police par les fondamentalistes
selon l'ambassade américaine
l'iran joue en sous-main un rôle
militaire crucial en irak
rencontre avec l'ambassadeur khalilzad
qui était en poste auparavant en
afghanistan nous avons des preuves
solides que des fournitures proviennent
d'iran nous avons les preuves que des
armes traversent la frontière iranienne
et nous avons aussi des preuves que
directement ou indirectement les
iraniens entraîne la guérilla est-ce
qu'on peut les voir
est-ce qu'on peut les films et j'ai vu
moi-même des preuves
je suis convaincu mais comme vous le
savez elles sont classées
confidentielles par les services secrets
et cela rend difficile de les rendre
aussi public qu'on soit officiellement
secret défense
pourtant sur un site d'opposition au
régime de téhéran
on accuse l'iran de fournir des armes à
la guérilla anti américaines comme par
exemple un lot de fusil
ultra-perfectionné esther h et 50
des armes capables de percer des
blindages de 5 cm et de tuer un homme à
deux kilomètres une information qui ne
laisse pas indifférent l'ambassadeur
nadja l'autre grande ville sainte d'irak
nadjar la ville cimetière où tout bon
shit espère se faire enterrer depuis
l'invasion américaine
un nouveau secteur a été créé pour y
accueillir les dépouilles de ceux tombés
au combat ou victimes d'attentats
et à ce petit jeu là je parlais tout la
cour royale
nadjaf c'est aussi le fief de l'armée du
mahdi la milice fondamentaliste chiite
anti américaine la plupart des
combattants enterrés ici n'obéissez
qu'un seul homme moktada al saber 33 ans
fils de l'ayatollah sadegh assassiné par
saddam hussein les fils est devenu le
leader incontesté des masses populaires
chiite irakien moktada al sadr est à la
tête de l'une des milices les plus
puissantes d'irak
l'engouement qu'il suscite chez les plus
démunis renforce chaque jour un peu plus
les rangs de sa milice aujourd'hui ils
ont signé comme un cessez le feu avec
les américains mais ils n'ont pas déposé
les armes
c'est sous la haute protection du chef
de la police de nadjaf que je suis remis
aux miliciens de l'armée du mehdi
ce vendredi est spécial
[Musique]
la mosquée de koufa est pleine à craquer
ils sont tous venus écouter leur guide
je suis le seul occidental à avoir été
invité à la prière
à
moktada al sadr n'a pas parlé depuis des
mois nous sommes au lendemain de la
nomination du nouveau gouvernement
moqtada al-sadr va aujourd'hui lui faire
ses recommandations tout l'irak
intentionnistes club avant tout j'exige
du nouveau gouvernement qu'ils répondent
aux souhaits de tous les irakiens le
retrait des forces d'occupation
américaines
c'est l'exigence de tout un peuple et
des autorités religieuses et de leur
faction le parlement comme le
gouvernement doivent oeuvrer pour avant
tout viré déloger cette forces
colonialistes qui a envahi notre irak
bien aimé nous appelons les pays amis
ceux qui respectent la souveraineté de
l'irak et nous leur disons de nous aider
car l'irak n'est pas le dernier
mais peut-être le premier des pays
occupés par l'amérique voilà pourquoi
nous tous les musulmans
nous devons être comme un bloc notre
destinée et communes
moktada al sadd air parle à mots
couverts mais quand il évoque des pays
amis tout le monde comprend qu'il pense
d'abord à lyon en janvier 2006 alors
qu'il n'avait jamais quitté le
territoire irakien moktada al sadr s'est
rendu à téhéran
officiellement en pèlerinage mais il a
aussi eu des contacts politiques avec
par exemple le ministre iranien des
affaires étrangères
l'iran est sans conteste le protecteur
de l'armée du mehdi
[Musique]
outre le fief de nadjaf moktada al sadr
et sa milice assurent la sécurité de
l'un des plus grands quartiers de bagdad
sadr city un bastion chiite radicale de
plus de deux millions et demi de
personnes
les milices iasi qui contrôle toute la
distribution alimentaire y compris
celles provenant de l'aide
internationale directement ou
indirectement l'iran exerce bien en irak
des influences multiples dans les
domaines économique politique religieux
et militaire
l'iran a de bonnes cartes en main pour
contrer les objectifs américains dans la
région
malgré l'optimisme affiché à l'ambassade
américaine
bien sûr le régime iranien est ambitieux
il veut dominer cette région d'un point
de vue idéologique et géopolitique
mais je crois que les efforts faits par
ce régime pour exporter son modèle et
dominer la région ne donneront rien
résoudre les problèmes de cette région
c'est un défi à relever pour notre
génération
un peu comme l'était la menace
soviétique à l'époque de la guerre
froide
si les américains ont gagné la guerre
il est encore trop tôt pour savoir s'ils
pourront un jour s'imposer dans ce
nouveau conflit
[Musique]
en